what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder and the
eternals is right around the corner well
shang chi is really right around the
corner but the eternals isn't that far
away and if you have not heard we are
supposed to be getting a new trailer for
the eternals tomorrow august 19th and
ahead of that we actually have learned a
lot of new details about the eternals as
a group and about each individual
character thanks to a recent article
from entertainment weekly because they
actually got to see some of the movie
they were given an exclusive
behind-the-scenes look and now they have
put together an article explaining to us
basically what they saw in each
character so here's a big sneak peek at
what's to come at the eternals and what
their individual powers are and motives
are and it's pretty long so we're just
gonna dive into it but if you're new and
you love to stay up to date on the mcu
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell i for one am truly
excited for this movie and some of the
things that some of these characters
have to say like angelina jolie said and
i quote it's certainly the biggest thing
i've ever done end quote and that's
coming from angelina jolie one of the
biggest actresses of all time but we
know marvel goes all out and when you
have a cast like this you definitely
definitely go all out but we're gonna
start with cersei gemma chan's character
and i'm basically going to go in the
order that entertainment weekly listed
these off so here's what it says about
cersei much of the eternals this story
centers on cersei who has the ability to
manipulate non-sentient matter so she
can manipulate matter that isn't alive
like she can control objects but not
humans she can change things and she
sort of helped humanity along the way in
little ways jimma chan explains unlike
some of the eternals sarzi has a real
love and respect for humanity and in the
present day she's working as a museum
curator and dating a human which of
course is dane whitman played by game of
thrones's kit harrington she also has a
long romantic history with richard
madden's icarus jimmy chan says she's
interesting because she is this immortal
being but she's very grounded as well
she's a little bit of a free spirit and
just loves being amongst humans so some
pretty big confirmations here one we
have her power she can manipulate
non-sentient matter two and we kind of
knew this she is indeed going to be
dating kit harrington's dane whitman aka
the black knight and three although we
definitely saw this in the trailers she
does have a romantic interest and
history with richard madden and she
loves being amongst the human she loves
the human species and this is going to
be good because it looks like the humans
are going to need some help at some
point in time during the eternals
because they're not supposed to
interfere but as it said here cersei has
kind of helped them out a long time so
i'm sure she'll fight for them and
speaking of richard madden his character
icarus is up next it says madden's
icarus is one of the most powerful
eternals with the ability to fly and
shoot beams of light from his eyes he
has a special connection with cersei but
they don't necessarily see eye to eye on
their approach toward humanity still
they have a complicated on-again
off-again relationship that stretched
throughout the centuries richard madden
says there's a deep level of romance and
two people that have been around for
thousands of years and yet still choose
each other so it definitely looks like
there's a little bit of a love triangle
going on here ultimately it does seem
like sarzi and icarus are going to end
up together they've essentially been
together for centuries but it just seems
like searsie loves humans a little bit
more than icarus cares to they're
essentially gods they're immortal beings
so he probably doesn't look too kindly
upon humans especially since his love is
dating one and richard madden said a
biggest challenge of his is playing an
immortal superhuman who has seen
everything over the last 7 000 years he
said how do you play them to not be
bored of everything because you've seen
it and done it next up is camille
nanjiani's kingo and about him it says
most of the other eternals have tried to
stay under the radar through the
centuries but nanjiani's kingo has done
the opposite making a living as a
bollywood star and it says that as an
eternal he also has the power to
manipulate energy with his hands so his
power is energy manipulation apparently
only with his hands though i'm wondering
if that means he can't just think it and
do it if he literally has to use his
hands to manipulate it
nanjiani also got an incredible shape
for this movie as i'm sure a lot of
people saw and he also trained a lot for
fighting and he said in regards to how
he got ready i just watched a lot of old
school hollywood stars whose characters
really enjoyed fighting and he did have
a really huge dance performance which
was apparently a big challenge for him
he said i'm not a dancer i have zero
rhythm i had to take months and months
of classes to do this so it was very
challenging but i know that if we could
pull this off and capture the joy and
excitement of a bollywood dance number
in a marvel movie that would be special
because i grew up watching bollywood
movies i knew every bollywood movie
until like the late 90s so to be able to
do a homage to the genre of movies that
i loved and grew up watching was really
special then we have sprite played by
leah mchugh and this is what it says
mchugh's sprite may look like a preteen
but like the other eternals she's
actually thousands of years old mchugh
says i sort of related to her in the way
that i've lived my whole life because i
look younger than i am i related to her
in that way and in wanting to grow up a
little bit but being stuck in a way she
said she tried to just absorb and learn
as much as she could from all of these
other amazing actors she said towards
the beginning of the filming i was in a
harness doing this crazy choreography
stunt scene and just thinking wow my
brothers are going to think i'm so cool
it was just a crazy moment because i've
never done any stunt work like that
before and it just all hit me at once
how insane all of this is then we have
fastos played by brian tyree henry the
article says that fastos is a brilliant
inventor with a mind for creating
weapons and technology and this is
pretty much in line with who he is in
the comics brian tyree henry says i
never in a million years thought i'd be
part of the mcu i have always been a
huge fan i've been obsessed with the
concept of superheroes and the concept
of mankind needing saving and i think
that when you get these group of people
together who just have these intimate
sense of superpowers and saving humanity
it's something that we all kind of need
it literally brings everyone together
regardless of where you're from i'm
still freaking out that i'm part of it
it also says that it's been rumored that
henry's character is openly gay and
married with a family which would make
him one of the marvel cinematic
universe's few confirmed lgbt
superheroes in which i'm pretty sure
that is confirmed i don't want to give
like 100 confirmation but i'm pretty
sure that is going to be the case in the
movie next up is makari and this is
really really cool because makari is
going to be the first deaf superhero in
the marvel cinematic universe and she's
played by a deaf actress makari is going
to be played by lauren ridloff and i'm
sure many people know her from the
walking dead and her power as an eternal
is she is super fast and we've seen this
briefly in the trailer and she says that
the ironic part about this is when i
started training for the role i was told
to stop running i was like excuse me
stop running really what they wanted to
do was focus on building the symmetry of
somebody who looks like a sprinter and
that they tend to be a bit more muscular
so i focused mostly on building muscles
especially my legs and she goes on to
say it makes so much sense to have this
diversity and representation within the
mcu because what the mcu is offering the
world is amazing they're offering a way
for us to hope to be able to get up and
keep going and fight for what's
important more and more people are
starting to see themselves in that
universe and that's powerful and i
really do believe that the eternals is
going to be an insanely powerful movie
not only as a movie itself but for the
people that are watching it and that's
me warren saying that that's not a quote
next up we have druid played by barry
keegan and his power is very interesting
it says that he's an eternal with the
ability to manipulate other people's
thoughts i was the last one to get into
costume he recalls of his first day on
set when i arrived and put it on for the
first time it was kind of nice to walk
out and see the rest of the cast
reaction they were like whoa it's a
weird feeling to see yourself like that
as soon as you put the boots on your
posture transforms you definitely notice
how your whole demeanor and everything
just changes salma hayek actually says
there is something savage about barry
keegan he's incredible speaking about
his performances so i'm sure druid is
going to be a character that's going to
be pretty interesting and pretty intense
especially since he has the power to
manipulate other people's thoughts which
is something that he does kind of do in
the comics and why it's rumored that he
actually could be sort of a villain in
this film but we'll have to wait and see
on that next up is don lee's gilgamesh
not to be confused with giglamesh it's
gilgamesh some people have been saying
that i pronounced that wrong but nope it
is g.i.l gamesh gilgamesh and the korean
actor don lee describes gilgamesh as
extremely powerful and the strongest
warrior of the eternals he's protective
over his family and humans and he has a
solid dependable character that serves
his team in battle at the same time he's
a funny guy and has a sense of humor it
also says that he has a deep connection
with angelina jolie's thena and he
prefers to use his fists in battle often
taking out enemies with a single punch
he says that fit me perfectly because
i'm a long time boxer myself for over 30
years since i was a kid gilgamesh's
action is based on boxing so i could add
real boxing movements and that's just
going to make for a great character
instead of an actor having to kind of
learn boxing within a year he had been
boxing for over 30 years so it's going
to be a very natural performance for him
and it sounds like his character is
going to be a rather important and
prominent one and then we have the
wonderful salma heyex ajac and it says
hayek wasn't sure what to expect when
marvel reached out and said they wanted
to meet with her about a potential
project but when she found out that zao
was involved she immediately said yes
she said i was shocked imagine in your
50s and you get a call from this
director that you're crazy about who
says you're going to be a superhero it
says hayek immediately fell in love with
the character of ajax the eternal stoic
and powerful leader who also has the
ability to heal the character was
originally written as a man in the
comics and in early conversations with
zao it was hayek who suggested leaning
into her femininity and approaching her
as the mother figure of the group she's
full of contradictions the actress says
she's the bridge between the eternals
and the celestials and it's never easy
to hold two sides together and i'm
curious to see what's going to come from
her character because we know that we're
going to see the celestials in this film
but we also know that the eternals are
really going to interact with the humans
a lot and it seems like she might have
to kind of choose sides which i would
hope she would choose her fellow
eternals and then we have the one and
only angelina julie's character athena
and it says angelina jolie is certainly
no stranger to blockbuster projects but
even she was surprised by the scale of
the eternals it's certainly the biggest
thing i've ever done she says as
somebody who's directed to watch the
production try to manage it it was a
huge thing to take on it says the
acrobatic thena is one of the group's
elite warriors and she can manifest
weapons out of thin air to prepare jolie
undertook ballet training to capture her
effortless grace as well as teaching
herself how to use various weapons most
of which were added in digitally in
post-production she says it's one of the
weirdest things to train for because
you're throwing things grabbing things
breaking things in half you feel a
little nuts you're just throwing your
hands out as if you're thinking is that
a sword is that a spear is that a lasso
what am i doing then you get into it and
it gets really fun but it's a puzzle and
this sounds like it's going to be
extremely cool because we've already
seen some of her weapons in the trailer
and we can tell that they're a little
bit different and now we know it's
because she is actually creating them
out of thin air out of nothing which is
going to be super cool to see it's
almost kind of going to be like hella
but i'm sure it's going to be actually a
lot cooler and there you have it a
little bit of a deeper dive into the
eternals and all of their powers
explained again i believe we're getting
a new trailer for the eternals tomorrow
we'll have to wait and see but be on the
lookout for that in the meantime let me
know what you think about all of their
powers and what you think about what's
going to happen in the eternals in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
don't forget to give the video a like
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you